تكلمنا بدايه الحلقه عن التنبؤ بالزلازل
وامكانيه ذلك علميا اناقشنا الموضوع مع
ضيفنا استاذ علم الزلازل وفي نفس هذا
السياق متداول اون لاين الكثير من
المقالات عن برمجيات ذكاء اصطناعي قيل انه
عندها القدره على التنبؤ بالزلازل واحسن
من العلم والبشر لكن لاي درجه هذا الكلام
دقيق احنا حبينا نتاكد وسالنا دكتور محمد
قاسم صديقنا طبعا في البرنامج علشان
يجاوبنا على هذا الموضوع
اهلا يا ساره واهلا في السعاده والسيدات
المشاهدين بالنسبه للذكاء الاصطناعي
والتنبؤ بالزلازل الاوراق العلميه كثيره
في هذا الجانب لكن ان تاخذ الاوراق
العلميه وتطبقها وتاتي بنتائج منطقيه
مقبوله فهذا امر صعب التنبؤ في الزلازل
يعتبر مثل التنبؤ حاله الطقس او مثلا
التنبؤ بالاسهم وما شابه من الصعب جدا
الوصول الى نتائج دقيقه في هذا الموضوع
ممكن يوصون الى نتائج مقاربه للصحه ولكن
لن تكون دقيقه ابدا التنبؤ في المستقبل
امر شبه مستحيل الان المشكله الاساسيه في
هذا الموضوع هي ليست ان هل هناك قدره في
التنبؤ وحتى لو كانت 99% لنفترض ان هناك
ذكاء اصطناعي استطاع ان يتنبا بقدره 99%
هل من الممكن ان الحكومات تتبنى وتستخدمها
في الانذار المبكر هنا المعضله لان
المشكله وين ان الاقتصاد يعتمد على مثل
هذه الاشياء اذا تنبا الذكاء الاصطناعي
بحدود زلزال قريبا
هل الناس عندهم الاستعداد لاقفال محلاتهم
هل الحكومه عندها استعداد ان يذهب الناس
في حاله من الهلع والركض وترك اعمالهم
وذهاب للمنزل والخروج من اخراج كل شيء فيه
هل الحكومه عندها الاستعداد ان تتحمل هذا
كله ثم بعد ذلك بما ان الذكاء الاصطناعي
الى اليوم غير قادر على التنبؤ في وقت
حدوث الزلزال هو غير قادر على التنبؤ حتى
في مكان الزلزال فتخيلي المستقبل انه يعلن
عن زلزال ولا يعرف بالضبط اين سيكون فتؤخذ
دائره كبيره من مساحه الارض للتنبع
فعدد كبير من الناس يتوقف اعمالهم عدد
كبير من الناس يخافون وينزعجون ويضطرون
للخروج وما شابه فهذه تسبب اشكاليه
اشكاليه من ناحيه القانون اشكاليه من
ناحيه الاخلاق اشكاليه من ناحيه كيف
تتعامل معها الحكومه وهل لرئيس دوله عند
الاستعداد ان يضحي حتى الحكومه ان تضحي
بسمعتها من اجل ان تصدر
اعلان بهذا الشكل ولا لا هذا الموضوع طبعا
امر يحتاج الى دراسه طويله ويحتاج الى دقه
كبيره جدا
لم نحصل عليها الى الان سواء من ذكاء
الاصطناعي او غيره من الادوات